welcome to this video playing
Grandmaster Vladimirovich Vladimirovich
now who is this isn't drinking voices
Boris scratcher not in your vision I
keep forgetting I knew that I have to
look that up they have to look that up
he's playing the Kings gambit doesn't
look like rock chef actually what chef
is more of a default default guy okay um
what isn't this winning material why
isn't this winning material check okay
so I can take on here I like on III so
okay I didn't win material directly but
it's not not bad it's just I mean he
will get get this back on only three
maybe Queenie for as a move
okay I wanted to be quick with c5 knight
c6 yeah maybe
Queenie 46
okay let's develop if he takes on c5 I
play Queen d5 was my idea or is this
nonsense
I don't think so I think I can recapture
on c5 with the Queen or mr. Bishop okay
if I take now Queenie for g6 now it
should be okay it's just training I okay
so he wants to just
we can a structure which which he
successfully did of course
okay we shipped to come to see for me
check yeah okay I have to exact I have
to realize that the opposite colored
bishops yeah this is kind of awkward but
thank you I have to do that I guess I'm
not the very welcome trade but
ultimately nothing that I can do okay
here okay let's let's check this here is
going to go before I guess did not
really appreciate that correctly this
before move but I can it's not not at
the end of the world but still g5 trying
for Bishop g7 to be to King each wife
Knight f4 so going here or to e5 going
here I guess
okay sample should be - I probably
playing without the King which is really
a good idea
check
let's think about this for one moment
him um no I have three for taking this
and the beep on his hanger is attacked
but he gets this passers getting
dangerous definitely will be okay and I
still have to do this I guess tonight
h-2a a5 Bishop e7 b6 I probably have to
play Bishop e7 first to try to stop this
business yeah so I wanted to take on b6
with the bishop now trying to draw this
end game which is probably I'm not sure
if there's some drawing chances but
Teague with the pony as a six so I have
to take here anyway I can't start with
this check though 95 check is there some
point in that
check check check all this checksum 95
check ok I have to play maybe some some
somewhere here I'm high morning was was
an opportunity maybe he can trick him
here
a knight f2 maybe he might trip my wish
of my knight yeah I have a hard time too
I have a hard time here too yes the
wrong bishop but it's difficult here to
trade stuff ok now this isn't a problem
with the wrong bishop
check-check
let you let let him show be cyanide
technique we will be fun to watch check
he will even manage but people sometimes
I think it's it's it's actually tricky
to do with little time but he will
manage that yeah very nice right he's
getting me in the right corner check
check check me yeah this is how it's
done very nicely done okay let's check
them um I definitely have some drawing
chances in this endgame but it's it's
not easy at all I feel that a bit later
there were chances but check it was it
was difficult of course with the with a
limited time so maybe some way around
here ever be if I'm precise but the comp
is not agreeing it gives plus free I was
not sure if maybe there's some kind of
line here along these there's nothing
really
now this is actually this is maybe an
eidm check which of course the computer
assesses is totally winning but there's
this issue of the wrong the wrong Bishop
you know and he only has two pawns and
it's probably still a win it's still a
win I guess na de pon I playing without
the King but it was difficult to get it
get it in the game maybe I should not do
that I don't know maybe it's it's it's
um it's um it's not not how would Abel
anyway it's it's possible without the
King it is tricky
it is really tricky check and Here I am
too late with taking I cannot take after
that this will promote okay so probably
have to have to improve somewhere
earlier and check this is really really
an annoying move maybe maybe I can I
really think that I should be able to
get some drawings on the same with the
opposite colored bishops I probably lost
too much time there with night before
and stuff now
it's um it's not a not a very attractive
task anyway um I probably should should
should simply improve in the opening
yeah here here thinking a moment would
have been good for example g6 and Bishop
h6 is quite strong keeps this pawn only
three yeah this is why his opening was a
bit a bit iffy but I did not think at
the right
and yet it should be quite okay but yeah
this is I did not really appreciate this
95 IDM it's very awkward after that I
really shouldn't be in any trouble here
this is this is definitely definitely
the case hmm so maybe Bishop f6 he is
better right and this kind of thing now
I played this a bit too quickly I'm
trying to not get into into too much
time pressure okay I hope you enjoyed
this thanks for watching